this is proof that the summer movie
season never slows down if it's not a
movie review it's a spoiler video if
it's not a spoiler video is to try the
review rinse and repeat love you summer
for that because we all love
entertaining [ __ ] there's a new trailer
for guardians of the galaxy out there
this movie it's it's the most
interesting of the Marvel movies coming
out I don't know if it'll be the best
but it's the most interesting concept
you have this band of misfits that
apparently are gonna save the galaxy and
they really play that up you need that
from the last trailer and this one star
looks like I look around me what do I
see i see losers but we might just be
the best hope ever I'm paraphrasing but
it's pretty much it and I like the tone
of the movie the movie looks like a lot
of fun and that's what you say about bad
movies you know it's like a Stephen
Sommers movie you're like it's fine this
might actually be fun and awesome I was
watching this trailer and I was like
this could be the next serenity it has
that vibe I am convinced beyond the
shadow of a doubt if Joss Whedon wasn't
pegged to do the Avengers movie he would
have been doing guardians of the galaxy
sex one would argue he'd be more at home
doing that this trailer doesn't show you
much more than what you already knew
from the first trailer but it does raise
a few questions in my mind
I don't read the guardians of the galaxy
comics so I know nothing about the
guardians of the galaxy when I heard
they were making his movie I was like
they're making a movie about the band of
people and a raccoon that talks in a big
tree but those are the questions I have
like star-lord is from Earth he says it
in this trailer so did we get
interstellar tribal was Tony Stark like
screw that arc reactor thing here now we
can travel in space boom there are other
humans are they all from Earth too is
this the same years like Avengers I
don't want to know in the comment
section or anything like that so don't
tell me because I'm very convinced
beyond the shadow of a doubt they're
gonna answer that in the movie I'm just
thinking out loud right now you this is
my thought process however I gotta say I
like the teaser trailer better because
of the song they use this one you got
that diner that's all great but that
hooked on a feeling song although it is
in this trailer also it's the prominent
song in the last one when it's all going
Guga Chaka ooga booga and it's all just
going down as a montage of action did
you see that [ __ ] in the movie theaters
that thing had a beat to it just
[Music]
chocka you're like yeah I want to sit
just because of that beat I feel like
rock it's gonna make the movie he could
be that character where you walk out
you're like rocket racoon he's just the
greatest it was this mass onslaught of
people just buying him a Marvel heroes
after this movie comes out I should
talking badass shooting attitude filled
raccoon that's all I want if that's what
I get Color Me happy Zoe Saldana is not
bad-looking at all did you see that you
see that obligatory ass shot not gonna
lie check that out I was gonna put that
as a thumbnail but I was like hey let's
be real here let's be that classy
youtuber that doesn't put asses on his
thumbnail
seriously though man they're all wearing
the same thing so what if that star-lord
that's what I would do if I were making
this trailer I would put that shot on
there so people like Zoe Saldana and
then when they see the movie they will
know it's just a dude this movie is
great humor I love the fact that I mean
there's the misfits in the movie and the
movie itself who wasn't skeptical about
this when I heard they were making
guardians of the galaxy I was like I
will that work but they're making it
work I love the tone I love the humor
like I said it could be the next
serenity and I'm looking forward to this
movie this could be the biggest surprise
of the Marvel Universe yet or the
biggest disappointment we don't know as
long as the villain in this movies
actually the villain in this movie he's
not an actor I think people will be okay
so the new guardians of the galaxy
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]